التوتر مستمره في محيط مسكن رئيس الحكومه
الباكستانيه السابق في لاهور اصرار الشرطه
على تسليم عمران خان مذكره استدعاء
للمحكمه تسبب في احتكاك بين الشرطه
وانصاري رئيس الوزراء المقال الذي يخشى
اتباعه ما يعتبرونها مكيده لاعتقاله
وتغيبه عن المشهد السياسي
[تصفيق]
لمحاوله تجنب اي مصادمات بين اتباع
والشرطه حاولت التقدم بتعهد رسميا لفريق
الشرطه الذي حاول اعتقاله بانني سامثل
امام القضاء يوم الثامن عشر من مارس
الجاري غير ان الشرطه رفضت علنا تسلم
التعهد وهو التصرف مخالف للقانون
لاهور عاصمه اقليم البنجاب الذي يستعد
لخوض انتخابات لعضويه البرلمان المحلي
شهدت اغلاقا لكل الطرق المؤديه الى مسكن
عمران خان بشاحنات استاجرتها الحكومه للحد
من حركه التنقل
منذ الليله الماضيه لم نتناول اي طعام
الكل يشتمنا لقد تضررت شاحنه كثيرا ولم
اتمكن من ابعادها وقت المصادمات فالحكومه
هنا استاجرت من الشاحنه واخذت مني
مفاتيحها
اليوم يعتبر من الايام السيئه فلاسباب
سياسيه يعاني
الناس ما الخطا
الذي قاهره وصعبه ومع ذلك لا يستمع رجال
شرطه لاي مراشده
امام القضاء الذي ينظر في قضايا رفعت ضد
عمران خان وضعت تفاصيل الخلاف الحالي
فطالب القضاء الشرطه بتاجيل محاوله اعتقال
خان عده ساعات ليبقى اصل الخلاف بين
الطرفين قائما ولا سيما بشان موعد تنظيم
انتخابات عامه في كل ارجاء باكستان
صدامات الشوارع واغلاق الطرق ما هي الا
ملامحه لل
خلافه بل والاصراعي على السلطه
[موسيقى]
منذ اشهر عده ويزداد خطوره كلما تصاعد
الاستقطاب الشعبي
عبد الرحمن مطر الجزيره لهون
[موسيقى]